is it possible that Kanye is an aging
hot chick mm-hmm okay
in that when a girl is hard mm-hmm she
doesn't need to be that funny for us to
laugh she's the stories don't need to be
that interesting for us to pay attention
right right
and Kanye when I say is hot I mean like
his content was hot back in the day the
music was unbelievable yeah that the red
Octobers when they dropped yeah you
remember the Nike dropped the [ __ ]
Red October yeah those are still like
the easy unbelieveable sneaker right and
the regular Yeezys for Nike were fire
yeah even when he transitions to the
easy brand with a DS that Dita's I'm not
a big fan but people love their clothing
right all of a sudden the music starts
to fall off a little bit fair to say
yeah okay
clothing kind of falling off a little
bit fair to say yeah kind of like an
aging hot chick when you're an aging hot
chick in order to get attention because
those looks are fading titties getting a
little saggy toes bunion up a little bit
the antics need to be that much crazier
you ever seen how aging hot chicks dress
they don't get more conservative ah it
gets Wilder right outfits get smaller
right eyelashes get longer titties get
mushed antics get crazier right aging
hot chicks lonely no friend they got the
[ __ ] housewives shows yeah none of
them have friends that's not weird
did they gotta be paid to have friends
yeah I didn't even think they were hot
chicks like if you came to me and you're
like hey I want to do a reality show
with you and your friends a big yeah I
got a bunch of friends this cool yeah
you wouldn't have to hire nine other
lonely people it's true right Kanye
who's honey kicking with his reality
show his reality show I'm starting to
think he understands that the content
they it the thing that made him hot the
sex factor or whatever for a chick yeah
which was the content he knows ain't
what it used to be the clothing ain't
what they used to be the music ain't
what it used to be so he's up in the
antics like crazy
long as I make up for it how long ago
was life of Pablo four years I think ya
might have been five years but then also
even that wasn't his best I thought that
was great
I liked life ah but I think album that
preceded it was Jesus Jesus and then
that was like some people didn't like me
that I remember life of Pablo saying
people saying he's back that's what we
all thought
right like Pablo trop like oh yeah yeah
got in his bag it's it this is who he is
yeah and before yeezus it was my
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy fans love
that might have been his best album
right right right right right okay
so look it's just an interesting way
that like he might be looking at content
not even content but like monetization
of his art and he might be realizing the
art ain't what it used to be and maybe I
can't create that kind of art maybe I
don't have the place for it to come
through and maybe I just want the money
maybe I'm comfortable I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is so what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna raise the antics the Kardashians
have no art but they have antics like a
[ __ ]
mm-hm and what are they aging hot chicks
aging mother [ __ ] hot chicken boy
here point kanye's net worth is three
bills
apparently forbes finally listed him as
a billionaire and it's when his quality
has fallen off cuz i was gonna say we
don't listen to his albums anymore we
don't listen well his last gospel album
nobody liked that [ __ ] but his net worth
is going up and that worth is going up
because it's all based on the clothing I
think and the we still cop that's the
thing we do but do we like Alan and we
had Kevin I saw a comic very funny
comment over here earlier he's like
honestly now I don't know if this is
true but he said that cos white people
are holding up Kanye yeah I would say
it's pretty factual I didn't realize
that was the case cuz I've never really
[ __ ] with a Kanye stuff outside the
music but like is it only white people
wearing the easies there's only white
people buying the clothes there's only a
few years ago I would say black people
were starting to be off easy a little
bit even before the TMZ [ __ ] and that
what tipped it over tip the scale yeah
yeah well as thing I don't even know is
Street where black dominated like any
are really black Domino so I'm saying
like yeah Portia's but still his
sneakers were hot at one point right
yeah they were hot like we were he was
saying that they were almost as good as
Jordan or whatever like jump man so now
it's like I haven't worn I have like
maybe four or five pairs I haven't worn
them since the TMZ situation over it
yeah so mark do you think that Jay has
fallen off actually here's a better
here's a better question you you know
more music than most people your age but
did you ever look at Kanye as like the
cool guy or did you look at him as like
an old head that made dope music no kind
of like my generation I think like
graduation and like like that's when I
first heard of Kanye I think okay so I
thought he was hot then and he was an
influencer to you you were like I want
to dress like hammer I want to look like
I yeah I got those shades with the
blinds on them yeah I went to hot top
with my sister I got this okay that's
what I'm saying
there was a time where he was like a
fashion icon would you still he got
billion dollars over I mean so not just
making clothes he actually looked dope
in clothes like we would see his office
like oh yeah he didn't look bad at the
rally with his bulletproof vest on she
was I that was so 50 cent 10 years ago
so that's older it hey man fashion comes
back that [ __ ] is cyclical why do you
have it there you know okay go I think
the Kardashians are trying to get him in
that Britney Spears situation though
concert oh my god we're going deep on
the [ __ ] conspiracy today Brad Kanye
what is it conservatorship Santa's
conservatorship yeah Britney Spears
apparently has this intense
conservatorship where her father and I
believe lawyer yes are in control of
every facet of her life
mm-hmm I don't even know she can post
without their permission or their team
can't own a phone she cannot own the
phone just her she is to have who she
dates approved by yep
certain people I mean any other stuff
that you know all financial decision all
financial decisions have to go through
though she is a child
yeah and they did it be as if her mental
break and
I was making a made a really interesting
point is that not only does she have the
mental break she attacked someone with
an umbrella that little [ __ ] but when
you do a physical act of violence you
can have someone else or the government
if you will constrict you of your
ability to like take onus on your own
behavior or take accountability for
owner behavior and even as adult put you
under the jurisdiction of or the
conservatorship of your father lawyer
etc mm-hmm so all this kind of cool
stuff is been happening on our Instagram
where people will comment hey if you
need help and you want to be freed wear
a yellow shirt and then should wear
yellow shirt her next video hey if you
want to be freed if it's really serious
wear a black shirt in your next video
should wear the black shirt um yeah and
it would be the most like to comment so
will be the one at the top right and
what you're saying is you think the
Kardashians are trying to like so take
advantage of Kanye's mental illness
mm-hm and why not [ __ ] got a
billion dollars he got how many kids wit
mm-hmm
with uh how many kids with campaign for
I think they're at the for now yep for
kids with Kim should take all that dad
is some devious [ __ ] right they are
devious people exactly they ruin every
man can pimp out her daughter they are
capable of any [ __ ] their look at every
man Rob they're gonna [ __ ] about Robbie
out here impregnating China to get
attention
I'm surprised Connie lasted this long I
am too honestly Lamar crackhead Bruce
Jenner Bruce Jenner Kris Kris Humphries
not even in the league and they were
married for like a month
yeah he's out the league [ __ ] and the
dude was 611 athletic 611 athletic and
Simmons cashew no more can't shoot Dan
Simmons is done you kid it tastes it at
Kardashian It's A Wrap
do you it gotta pee we're throwing
everything away yeah boy Travis Scott
still got it oh he got he got away he
got well he kicks will see we said about
Kanye early on we'll see nobody got away
he's never open up they're broken up
though it seems like sometimes they're
so together not like I look like I'm on
air
nothing you know hey Margo nothing about
that is it come on guys
[Applause]